[Music]
mr. Jack McBrayer you all know my next
guest from his hilarious remotes on this
show over the years well now he's
starring with Jack McBrayer in the new
Adult Swim series the jack and triumph
show please welcome triumph the insult
comic dog
[Applause]
[Music]
you would not wait any longer not from
there to here come back although you
lost a cigar already are you bill has me
he's down here feeding me more cigar
okay very nice well good to have you
here try them very good to have you
great to be here thank you so much for
having me on your podcast it's a TV show
but we'll let it go it's going to be
it's going to you've got that Nerdist
thing on the run yes you back we're
closing in no you're doing great man
this is very exciting you went to Poobah
yes feed you again yes I went to I went
to kuba yeah so kuba that's incredible I
thought after you left NBC you would
never want to return to a crumbling
dictatorship
[Applause]
where's my palm Oh crazy
[Laughter]
we need his paw for God's sake all right
let's go guys he's doing the Bamba
I see lebombo over there how about that
remember when you guys would make all
those jokes that la Bamba was gay yes
see and now we're past that we just
accept that he's gay you don't joke
about stuff like that it's no no it's
gram well you know what it is great to
have you back on our show and I know
you're doing some other shows and we're
just happy to ask we have been doing
amazing shows like The Today Show you
give it a shot
yes it's bindi believe me it's a lot
more fun here funnier than the today's
yes because they don't let you say stuff
you know they don't let you call NBC a
crumbling dictator they don't let you do
jokes like you want me to read some
jokes and these are jokes that day today
what is that wait these are jokes the
Today Show said you could not say yes
okay pay no attention to the Jewish hand
okay now I'm going to read jokes
I'm reading them from this paper my eyes
are looking at the piece yes that's
right cuz you're yes you're a real dog
yes please don't we putting a sign up
there that's writing on it
oh don't get that Jewish and back
you're ruining it for the children I'm
sorry sorry we're dog okay here's one
the Wiener jokes the other jokes that
were cut from the today's hot Friday
today's show today show jokes that
didn't make it didn't make it hey Al
Roker here's what's happening in your
neck of the woods
chin waddles you see because he has lots
of skins here right by his chin yes you
see I think they did you a favor
yes hey I ran into Matt Lauer in the
hallway what happened it looks like NBC
suspended his hairline for six months
Today Show I'm sorry I'm a little thrown
you know what with Jon Stewart retiring
then Brian Williams being suspended an
hour later Wow
that was a that was a tough week for
fake news anchors so let's move on I got
one more Oh God you know it's been a
rough year not for just Brian but for
his daughter Allison from the showgirls
oh yeah ruff here for Brian and Allison
what with the two of them both getting
their asses chewed out there okay
Anke Heke a lot of HBO fans in the
audience to have seen that episode you
see because of the analingus yes yes
wasn't an episode of girls but you'd
have to have seen it
you